joe louis aubert a lieu alors idéal
standard même vous ne savez pas vous
avez écrit ce titre il est bien il est
très bien très bien ce qui est très bien
pensé que tout le monde a un idéal
standard en ce moment en quoi c'est ça
non alors il faut pas d'avoir mais à un
petit idéal minimum moi quelque chose de
simple quelque chose d'amoureux de
facile le guide est elle standard c'est
désormais dédié à votre ami d'enfance
olivier caudron alias olive de lili drop
qui est mort en janvier dernier de la
tuberculose avec qui vous étiez allé
voir les ou way au théâtre des champs
elysées 69
voilà et qu'ils aient travers ces états
unis en stop avec qui un avec qui j'ai
commencé téléphone mais s'adresse quinze
jours avec lui quoi là il a fait son
groupe et vous dites une partie de
moi-même s'en est allé reçues on alter
ego on disait de journée deux faces de
la même pièce on a failli chanter cette
chanson de mecs qui se regarde dans la
même pièce oui c'est mon voisin de
palier quoi quand j'étais petit et voilà
il m'a appris beaucoup de choses il m'a
emmené en faites ce que je vous rapporte
dans les chansons je pense que
c'est un peu de sa liberté 1 en fait on
rapporte qu on rapporte le génie de ce
qu'ils peuvent pas qu'ils peuvent pas
être là parce qu'ils sont trop fou c'est
ça on a connu de belles trop fou pour
être là eh ouais et c'est leur histoire
que je raconte en général dans mes
chansons
le soir
dis moi vous devez nous imiter mick
jagger de quartier mais il faut que
personne ne le regarde pas d'accord
personnes étudient près vous personne ne
regarde
estelle arthur jean le maux berges vous
laisser filer pour venir pour blind test
qui va être grand bleu à une caisse de
la mort j'espère tennis est là